(laughter)
(patriotic music)
Hi, I'm Sal, founder of the Khan Academy.
- And I'm Kim, Khan Academy's
U.S. History fellow.
- And it being July, the
month of our nation's birth,
as well as an election year,
a kind of not-so-exciting election year,
we thought we would spice
things up a little bit
by creating a crowdfunding
campaign to sponsor
American history and government
content on Khan academy.
The goal is to answer all
the questions you might have
about our history and our government.
Anything from what's an executive order,
to how the Supreme Court works.
But to make it happen,
we need your support.
It'll help you learn, but even more,
it'll help your fellow citizens learn,
so that we can have a deeper, richer,
and more spirited democracy.
- So help us make history at Khan Academy
with our very first crowdfunding campaign
to create education by the
people, for the people.
- So Kim, you've got a
PhD in American History,
and you create and curate
a lot of our content,
what are we gonna do as
part of this campaign?
- Well, I think what's exciting
about what we're doing here,
is that this is going to
be a easy to understand,
completely non-partisan way for people
to learn more about our government,
and to become engaged and active citizens.
- Very exciting.
We're looking to raise
$300,000 by July 28th,
and to put that in perspective,
the content we're going
to create is going to have
more information than all of
the political ads combined,
for a very small fraction of the cost.
And shortly after that, we're gonna start
putting the content up, that
Kim and I and others create,
to answer all of your questions.
- You can also get some
amazing Khan Academy swag
and perks by backing us here on Indiegogo.
- We look forward to your support.